a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono vari j
e oggi iniziamo noi diciamo che cosa sto
dicendo continuiamo a the small office
ragazzi mi avete chi allora avevo
chiesto lo scorso episodio se volevate
che la continua sì perché non sapevo se
a vincere sarà ancora mi avete risposto
in 50mila dicendo continua la ti ammazzo
e allora mi sa che devo continuare la
per forza dai ragazzi questa dovrebbe
essere la mappa finale the small horse
due praticamente reggae diviso in panne
diviso che è successo chi è quello
ragazzi mi sta facendo cos'è raga ha
chiesto qui
oh cazzo raga aiuto a chi è questo odio
si sta avvicinando pericolosamente ea
una lingua che buongiorno si no
veramente sei ragazzi è un figo e lui è
il nuovo modello di abercrombie ragazzi
è fantastico ok meglio che vada avanti
prima di fare figure di merda perfetto
io passo di captare cos'era quella roba
guai a voi si è spaventato un'altra
volta il vostro comandante non tollero
questo comportamento nel colpo marin
come ti chiami faccia di merda
ok senza faccia meglio così ragazzi non
è normale questo posto non ho capito
bene che cosa ci sto a fare qui resta
nota di cioccolato non so se la do
portavano anche parte c'è un bambino al
genoa da via da bambino perché magari
serve tabella ma la mamma lo zio segnato
che va l'educazione di merda ragazze il
progetto e cos'è la mia è una balla
faccia lo sappia presente che c'è già
muro una videocamera una video khamis
pia no siamo in un reality ma l'inter
cosa vuoi
maretta stronzo cosa misfits chi è che
ti manda temi che ti manda ora lo vuoi
parlare alleati schianto the ok ha forse
devo credo che debba metterla qui forse
c'è grande ok questa è una cosa molto
brutta perchè succeda no cos'è raccolto
per questo ora con una jam ragazzo ha
raccolto un agente ma tu continua spiare
sta tranquillo la gemma che me ne faccio
dell'agenda non lo so forse deve usarla
per credo non lo so per aprire la porta
sempre funzionato maledizione grande
ragazza io ho veramente paura andare
avanti in tema perché non so che cosa
succede sono veramente cose brutte
c'è ancora questa ragazza mi puoi
allungare il collo un secondo perché era
veramente figo devo tornare indietro
vero non lo sa l'unica porta rimasta
perfetto torniamo indietro con dio ci
sono dei cani davanti all ok perfetto
adesso si può passare
non chiedetemi perché va bene andiamo
avanti perché penso che il gioco voglia
che io vado a letto
[Musica]
ogni tanto le musiche 4 mika salo di
brutto
[Musica]
ciao amico come tutto a posto
sì però stai calma ok tolgo il disturbo
grazie mille
ma chi è quel perché c'è un ometto king
ragazzi mi sono detto king
ecco cos'è c'è uno c'è un ovetto no va
beh questa è la cosa più epica
l'invasione degli ovetti kinder guardare
questo mi sembra più un uovo di pasqua
che un ovetto ma vabbè io ce la metto
kinder se ce l'ho io e tu no brutto
stronzo sono io
va bene ci sono gli ovetti kinder in
media tutto normale
va bene cosa ci devo fare con questi la
gamma perché c'è una mega scopa che
blocca la porta fate milan ok ok
perfetto l'ovetto kinder neri è stato in
grado di distruggere la mega scopa senza
neanche farlo apposta va bene così
ragazzi fantastico siamo che c'è io io
veramente non so perchè gioca ste cose
ma la cosa degli ovetti kinder strada
epica vi giuro
vabbè fantastico che mi è venuta qui
anche di mangiarli ovetti kinder poi
cosa fare se non in frega vabbè c'è
cos'è sta roba ragazzi devo è un
platform devo saltare su sti cosi si è
allora vediamo se riesco a fare un salto
abbastanza lungo c'era gradino prefetto
il carico mi inquieta sta roba sembra
una faccia cosa devo fare
vado a una porta finta bene ragazzi cè
un makeup buongiorno ragazzi chi è
quello lì sotto non lo so va bene un
importo andiamo avanti sono ste porte
finte c'è qualcuno gli ha questo sito si
apre perfetto
sta diventando inquietante la mappa
ragazzi non è normale cos'è sta roba chi
è quella sul muro o mio dio e
inquietantissimo mio dio cos'è sta roba
ragazzi non si oltrepassano tutti si
cosi no perché non devo a trovare la via
se no mica ci metto ora sono passi
avanti ovviamente ci siamo
mourinho c'è un po di da solo ma
poverino chi è che ti ha lasciato qui
che è brutto stronzo duro figlio va beh
allora facciamo una cosa stai qui vado a
cercare aiuto si ferma è ferma arrivo
siamo in un altro labirinto cioè sono
due ok se ne sbloccato un altro perfetto
c dove stiamo andando non lo so c'è un
altro pony c'è un coniglio da lasciate
conigli e miu miu
ok me ne vado
raga aiuto mi scoprono [ __ ] rimani
lì dentro perfetto è il ragazzo che non
scappare anche veloci dove ecco il
titolo no veramente è troppo sfonderà la
porta chiude chiude ok ho trovato un
coniglio non so se ti serve ma non
trovando grande cos'è sta roba mirato e
laudano non mi serve devo aprire la
porta non si sa se apre grazie grazie
milano adesso sei in compagnia
ho trovato il compagno di giochi quindi
rimani pure lì perfetto ragazzi ci siamo
stiamo andando avanti piano piano cosa
c'è qui dietro ma che cazzo io lo so ma
perchè perchè fai questo
oddio come testimoniato ragazzi ok è la
situazione molto brutta aiuto no devo
riuscire ad aggirarla lo aspettate un
attimo vai vai vai vai vai vai vai e
vieni vieni qui ok fermo col cazzo cazzo
cazzo che ci posso fare
vieni qua maledetto stronzo vieni di
quadro e vai aiuta
è brutta la faccenda molto giusta dove
andando non lo so non m'interessa
trovati da
diranno mai così poi così madonna chiudi
chiodi che opaca
calma ragazzi l'abbiamo ha girato ce
l'abbiamo fatta spero che non sfondi
tieni d'occhio la porta ok ragazzi
dovremmo esserci stavolta credo si la le
vocine mi fanno paura veramente c'è cosa
c'è di quando la capolista non lo so
sono andato già troppo avanti quanti ce
ne sono
agli otto sto morendo tra l'altro devo
riuscire ad aggirarlo alle solo se
riesco a fare tipo il rugby faccio finta
consenta un cazzo mi ha fatto malissimo
ma tentiamo lo stesso di raggirarlo
facendo fritto di gente bene abbiamo
fatti non c'è più penso di averlo
seminato credo forse cruz e ragazzi non
abbiamo seminato forse no quanti sono
tra pochi
al minimo sabbia dove cosa perché perché
dovessimo finire
no ragazzi c'è non ci credo c'è solid
snake e lui no ti ho riconosciuto
maledetto vieni qui vieni qua non ci
posso credere è il mio mito dei
videogames in una scatola fantastico
cavalchiamo la leggenda
va bene sono sopra snake deco sesto
posto fantastico perché accesso disney
va beh non importa ciao
oggi grazie grazie mille ne vuoi un po 6
ci sono dice di black
c'è di tutto normale c'è il bambino di
prima che gioca ancora così c'è una
paresi al diritto qui
vabbè è troppo giovane per guidare per
lo più sei anche alcolizzato non puoi
gli standard il bambino sta andando
contro la scatola non è normale bravo
grandissimo ma me la macchina no vado a
piedi va bene gli occhi e di lei si
chiama bambino vai cos'è fuori dei guard
è nuovo beh io seguo i banchi è quello
cos'è quella roba di ragazzi c'è un tipo
ai contrario cos'è senti co2 che stai
andando col lockhart piper favore contro
quei cosi perchè mi stanno dando
fastidio
vieni con me dovrà piede
sull'acceleratore costantemente devo
farli sfondare il muro che vieni qua
beccatevi klaus franz è ok
non è che non ha funzionato sei perfetto
da ragazzine anche il bambino
neanche il bambino che è successo non lo
so ora non so che giusy che è successo
ma soltanto marmi bene chi è questo è
quello che è quello di happy feet
perfetto ragazzi c'è quello di happy
feet
io ho c'è una porta qui entriamo nella
porta e non che l'episodio vi sia
piaciuto fatemi sapere se volete che lo
continui sfottò nei commenti
come solito ragazzi se vi do è piaciuto
al sotto commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non i video
tratte nella descrizione
se non siete iscritti iscrivetevi non ci
rivediamo in un prossimo vito belle
ragazze
[Musica]